subventions devront... piloté
par la ministère des sports
Onge pour lutter contre les abus
dans le monde du sport.
(signal sonore de départ)
- La skieuse Geneviève Simard
avait 12 ans lorsqu'elle
a été agressée sexuellement
pour la première fois parl'entrt
qui a été reconnu coupable
en 2017 d'avoir commis
des crimes sexuels sur
neuf victimes entre 1991
et 1998.
GENEVIÈVE SIMARD,
ancienne skieuse olympique
- Mon enfance a été volée...
Le ski était...
Le ski était ma passion.
- Cinq ans après l'incarcération
de son agresseur, l'ancienne
athlète olympique se réjouit
qu'Ottawa s'attarde à
ise qui touche,
année après année, de nombreuses
disciplines sportives au Canada.
- Je trouvais que c'était
long avant qu'on voit
les changements. On en a
tellement entendu parler.
On était comme pas assez tannés
entre guillemets. Mais là,
avec cette annonce-là, t'sais,
il va falloir qu'il y ait
des critères très spécifiques
pour avoir droit au financement,
puis on le sait, dans le sport
au Canada, on est vraiment liés
- À compter d'avril 2023,
Sports Canada pourra exiger
des fédérations sportivesortives
de remplir certaines conditions
en matière d'imputabilité
ou de bonne gouvernance
en échange de financement.
Une façon de s'attaquer
à cettedénonciation
qui s'apparente au mouvement
#MoiAussi, souligne la ministre
des Sports.
PASCALE ST-ONGE,
ministre fédérale des Sports
que si c'est
juste les médailles,
quand on n'en a pas,
puis qu'on a vécu des mauvaises
expériences pendant le chemin
qui noussque-là,
ça devient juste une expérience
négative, puis ça peut pas
être ça le sport. le sport. le .
- Au cours des derniers mois,
les allégations concernant des
abus sexuels, de la maltraitanct
surface dans plusieurs
disciplines, que ce soit
en natation, en gymnastique
ou en ru
L'ancien athlète olympique
Jean-Luc Brassard considère
le plan de la minige
comme un pas dans la bonne
direction.
JEAN-LUC BRASSARD, ancien
athlète olympique en ski acrob.
- Maintenant, c'est importan
aussi que, vraiment,
les bottines suivent
les babines, parce que,
dans le monde fédéré sportif,
c'est les mêmes personnesqui so.
- Des dispositions pour rendre
le sport plus sécuritaire
au Canada afin qu'il se pratique